>> Vic Gundotra: To introduce the next section,
I'd like to invite up the product lead for
a new initiative, Rishi Chandra.
Rishi, come on up on stage.
[ Applause ]
>>Rishi Chandra: All right.
Thank you, Vic.
And thank you for all being here.
We're going to have some fun today.
I'm going to introduce you to Google TV, a
new platform --
[ Cheers and applause ]
>>Rishi Chandra: Thank you.
-- a new platform that we believe will change
the future of television.
But before we start talking about the future,
let's talk a little bit about the present.
I tried to pull together a few interesting
facts to just help convey how important TV
is to the world today.
So let's just go through those facts really
quickly.
First interesting fact: Five hours per day.
That's the average amount of time an American
spends in front of the television.
And, in fact, people are watching more TV
now than they ever were in the past.
That's pretty amazing.
Second interesting fact: $70 billion.
That's the annual advertising spend in the
U.S. alone on TV.
There's still no better medium to reach a
wider and broader audience than the television.
And then third interesting fact: 4 billion
TV users worldwide.
4 billion.
That's just staggering.
Even if you compare to very large markets,
like the mobile market, which has a couple
billion, or the PC market, which has a billion.
For a developer, there is no bigger market
than the TV market.
And the reality is, people just love television.
[ Laughter ]
>>Rishi Chandra: Right?
I love TV.
And I'm not embarrassed to say I watch a lot
of television.
So why is that?
Well, it turns out that TV just works.
Right?
It's easy.
It's reliable.
And it gets you access to really cool stuff,
my favorite sports, my favorite movies, my
favorite shows.
In fact, it's become such a natural and predictable
part of our lives that you don't even have
to think about it anymore.
There aren't many technologies that can say
that.
And as other technologies evolved and changed,
TV's basically stayed the same.
And to many people, that's actually pretty
comforting.
But increasingly, more and more of my entertainment
experiences in the living room are actually
not happening on the TV.
Right?
They're happening on my mobile phone or my
PC.
And that's really being driven by the Web.
The Web has completely transformed the PC
space, and much more recently, transformed
the mobile space, with the introduction of
the smartphone.
But even today, the Web has had very limited
adoption in the premier entertainment device
in your living room, the TV.
And so you're kind of stuck there.
Right?
There's two completely separate worlds for
most users.
One world where I have all this great, compelling
content on my television, my favorite sports,
my favorite shows, my favorite movies.
And then this other world where I have all
my great Web videos and my favorite Web sites.
So what ends up happening?
Well, naturally, users adjust.
But they adjust by doing unnatural things
to make it all work.
Let me give you an example.
This happens at my house all the time.
[ Laughter ]
>>Rishi Chandra: And it might resonate with
many of you here as well.
Family and friends huddle around this small
PC to watch really cool Web content.
This just doesn't make sense.
Video should be consumed on the biggest, best,
and brightest screen in the house.
And that's your TV.
It's not a PC, it's not a phone or anything
in between.
So how do we actually start bringing these
two worlds together?
I'll be the first to admit that we're not
the first to make an attempt on this.
Right?
Many people have tried.
And today, many devices now in the living
room will actually be connected to the Web.
But if you look at the data today, it's still
pretty limited adoption.
Now, I'm going to argue that there's three
reasons why many of the solutions today just
haven't made much traction.
They have three major limitations.
First limitation: They all try to dumb down
the Web for TV.
Here's the problem when you try to dumb down
the Web.
Then you're effectively recreating the Web.
Does that sound familiar to people in this
room?
It's WAP all over again.
[ Applause ]
>>Rishi Chandra: Right?
And what we learned in the mobile space is
that it just doesn't scale.
Yeah, maybe you'll get 20 apps, 50 apps, maybe
a hundred.
We need to find a way to bring the entire
Web to the television.
Second limitation, they're all closed.
Closed does not work anymore.
Once a user experiences the freedom to go
anywhere they want to go on the Web, they're
not going back.
And third, many of these solutions today make
you choose between TV or Web.
The minute that user has to hit that dreaded
input selector button to go from TV to Web,
you've lost 90% of them.
Because they don't know how to get back.
[ Laughter ]
>>Rishi Chandra: And the reality is, the choice,
if you give a user a choice between TV or
Web, they're going to choose TV.
That's the experience they know.
So what's the answer here?
Well, we have our opinion, obviously.
We believe it takes -- it requires taking
the best of what TV has to offer today and
the best of what the Web has to offer today,
and bringing them into a single, seamless
experience.
It really is about how do we make TV and Web
better.
So with that, I'm very happy to introduce
Google TV.
[ Applause ]
>>Rishi Chandra: Where TV meets Web and Web
meets TV.
Now, before we dive into the demo, which I
know you guys are all anxious for, I want
you to remember four ways that we believe
we are going to redefine the television experience.
First, we're going to show you how you can
spend less time finding and more time watching
your favorite content.
Second, we're going to also show you how you
can control and personalize what you watch
and when you watch it.
Third, we're going to make your existing TV
content much more interesting.
I'll show you how.
And, finally, we're going to make your TV
much more than a TV.